في اوكرانيا اسلحه مختلفه تدخل ساحه
القتال حلفائك الغربيون يتحركون في اتجاه
امدادها بمركبه قتاليه مدرعه لاول مره
فرنسا اعلنت عزمها ارسال مركبه قتاليه
مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس 10 ار
سيلكاف استراليا من جهتها قالت انها قدمت
لك اياه في 90 من مركبات التنقل المحميه
من طراز بوشماستر وهي وحدات مدرعه معززه
ضد الالغام ونيران الاسلحه الصغيره
وتهديده اخرى واشنطن هي الاخرى تدرس ارسال
مركبات براد للقتاليه الى اوكرانيا وهي
عربات مزوده بمدفع قوي من الوسائل
الاساسيه التي يستخدمها الجيش الامريكي
لنقل القوات في ساحه القتال منذ منتصف
الثمانينات مركبه من شانها ان تمنح
اوكرانيا مزيدا من القوه القتاليه وتعزز
قدرتها في حرب الخنادق اوكرانيا تستخدمه
ايضا صواريخ
الامريكيه الصنع تطلق من راجمات صواريخ
تقذف رشاقه صاروخيه وتحمل الراجمه 40
صاروخا من
عيار22 ميليمتر تطلق جميعها خلال 20 ثانيه
ادخال الفرقاطه الادمره القرش كوف المزوده
بصوارخه الى الخدمه العسكريه لتتمتع
بقدرات عسكريه كبيره وتعتبر من اكثر
الروسيه تطورا لديها خاصيه حمل صواريخ
مختلفه منها كاليبر وكين جالوت سيركان
وكروز يمكنها تنفيذ ضربات قويه ودقيقه في
البحار واليابسه صاروخ سيركونا
الاستراتيجي فرط الصوتي الذي يستطيع حمل
رؤوس مختلفه ومنها النوويه تفوق سرعته
سرعه الصوت قادر على ضرب اهداف على مسافه
تزيد عن الف كيلومتر
تطورات تاتي في وقت تتوقع واشنطن استمرار
القتال الانيف لاشهر اخرى في جبهه القتال
الشرقي
بلال الوجديني العربيه